hello I'm paget Brewster and today we
will be discussing Deborah Sampson the
first woman to take a bullet for America
cheers okay
in Plimpton Massachusetts Deborah
Sampson becomes an indentured servant to
Jeremiah Thomas lucky for her Jeremiah
was a fierce Patriot and taught her how
to do everything that other girls
weren't being taught and so she grows up
to be an incredible badass so she's
thinking what am I gonna be I want
adventure I want to serve my country so
I think I think I want yeah I want to
fight in the Revolutionary War
so she sews a men's outfit she's like
I'm gonna make trousers or britches
trouser breeches and a waistcoat and uh
what's a waistcoat waistcoat I think is
a vest coat it's it's a waste what just
a waste yeah you're approaching dad
humor but you're not a dad
how do you know oh do you have a baby
okay so she sews everything up cuts her
hair up she also has to take gauze and
strap her boobs down was she like oh my
gosh what was she like oh my god oh my
gosh holy Shh
I'm just embracing my fatherhood but so
Deborah Sampson looks at this young man
and says my name is Robert Robert
Shurtliff
and they accept her him in George
Washington's army and she develops an
incredible reputation all the other
soldiers are saying holy this
Robert Shurtliff he's badass he's right
out in front he's the fastest runner in
the army but a tarry town in the middle
of the Revolutionary War Robert Debra he
is fighting the British and out of the
blue
blammo she gets shot in the thigh with a
musket ball duh Deborah Sampson is
historically the first woman to take a
bullet for America the other soldiers
are like dude Bobby Bobby Shurtleff you
okay but she has to keep her identity
safe so she's like
[Laughter]
yep got this got this I'm good you're
cool I'm cool that voice is hard okay oh
this is where it gets crazy
she slinks off to the woods like this I
cannot go to the hospital I cannot let
anyone find out that I'm a woman so she
takes out a penknife
jabs at endure thigh gonna dig out this
musket ball digs it out she's like well
I can sew sews it up and says
America I care about you so much I'm
gonna cry I don't want to cry let it out
you think I won I'm talking to America
okay unfortunately Debra gets crazy
fever sick like again I can't but third
there passed out fever duh she is
hospitalized the one thing she's been
trying to avoid so doctor Barnabas
Binney is like okay here's the solider
kind of a badass soldier alright I'll
see what's wrong takes off Robert
Shurtliff
clothing what there's like binding on
the chest maybe there's something wrong
that here cuts it open boobs
and he goes okay it's so crazy how it
seems so easy when you're sober to tell
a story okay wait where was I
wait I know so he takes care of her for
seven months and she says thank you for
taking care of me if there's anything I
can do to repay your kindness please let
me know and he says actually will you do
me a favor and take a letter to my
friend General John Patterson
so she delivers the letter to John
Patterson general says thank you young
lady he reads this letter looks at her
and says private Robert Shurtliff are
you a woman pretending to be a man to be
a soldier and she says general I only
lied because I wanted to serve my
country please don't send me to jail and
he says young lady I think what you've
done is better and braver and stronger
then so many men and I'm gonna give you
a dishonorable I'm gonna give you a
sorry I'm gonna give you an honorable
discharge and that Paul Revere the
superstar of the American Revolution
it's like I'm a big American Hero
but I think you're the babe
it's incredible that more than 200 years
ago this woman wanted to make a
difference so she becomes this
cross-dressing
bullet diggin badass who fought her
balls off lol no pun intended
who's the dad joke now
you